Speaker 1: You know, one of the biggest scams
perpetrated and perpetuated by the American
right is that they are the patriotic ones.
They are the ones who support the troops.
They are the ones who support the police police.
They are the ones who are about America first.
And as if you needed more proof that this
is an utter and pathetic lie, over the last
24 hours, we have seen, first of all, Republicans,
right wingers and right wing media hosts root,
literally root against the United States in
the Olympics, rooting against the women's
soccer team, are rooting for other countries
to win.
Make fun of gymnast Simone Biles for her pulling
out of competition yesterday, the day before
yesterday, with the time difference with Tokyo.
I don't know exactly when it was over the
last 24 to 36 hours making fun of her.
Not exactly America.
First, patriotic behavior in terms of how
you would relate to or discuss someone who's
halfway around the world representing the
United States in athletic competition.
And then yesterday, after the first day of
testimony of the House Select Committee investigating
the January six Trump riots after four police
officers whose lives were threatened as they
attempted to defend the capital on January
6th, widely, Republicans and right wing media
hosts ridiculed the police officers and laughed
at the police officers and made a mockery
of the things that they said in their testimony
yesterday.
We're going to look at some clips and just
remember, when you look at this, they say
they support police.
They say they defend law enforcement.
They call themselves patriotic.
Here it's Tucker Carlson, literally chuckling
at the things we heard from one of the officers,
Officer Phonon yesterday.
Look at this.
Speaker 2: People he doesn't agree with in
Washington.
And that is unacceptable.
And it should make you very nervous.
Watch on site the psychological trauma he
endured as an excuse for ditching our Bill
of Rights.
Yeah, I've been left with the psychological
trauma and the emotional anxiety of having
survived such a horrific event.
Speaker 1: A very dismissive chuckle from
Tucker Carlson, this guy we're supposed to
believe he's a patriot and that he supports
the troops and he supports police, except
when he doesn't because it's just really not
convenient.
It's really not convenient, because if you
say, wow, we should listen to the testimony
of these officers, it implies some really
horrible things about the people who participated
in those Trump riots.
Next here is a clip from Newsmax.
This is hosted a grant think field grant has
never been a law enforcement officer, didn't
serve in the military, but he refers to Republican
Congressman Adam Kinzinger, who is a veteran
as a pansy, and then he mocks another Capitol
police officer.
When the police officer told us that he thought
he was actually going to die on January 6th.
Let's look at the next clip
Speaker 2: and laid on from other law enforcement
agencies.
I'm afraid to think what could have happened
on January six.
So, Grant, that's a pretty good question.
Do you expect that this will answer that question
or pursue it further?
No, I love that he's reading the statement.
I think the statement may have actually backfired
on him because, you know, the leader of the
Capitol Police really is Nancy Pelosi, by
the way.
Speaker 1: What does it mean?
I love that he's reading the statement.
Is that like a dig at that officer from the
Dominican Republic?
Is it a dig at the guy's English language
proficiency?
I don't even know what it means that he says
I love that he's reading it like, oh, if he
wasn't reading it, he wouldn't be able to
speak.
I don't even understand what that means.
Speaker 2: So you've got to ask Nancy Pelosi
about why they didn't have the backup they
so-called needed.
But, you know, Heather, as I watch this hearing,
they told us it wasn't going to be political.
And then I got this pansy of a congressman,
Adam Kinzinger, and crying as if he can't
hold it together here.
It's nonsensical.
It's about the most political thing I've ever
seen.
It is all theater, typical to democratic fashion.
It is all based in emotion.
I'm having a real hard time believing a lot
of what I'm hearing because the video doesn't
back up nearly all of it.
One officer said he thought it was going to
be the moment he died.
Well, there were no guns at this place.
I've watched guns at Black Lives Matter protests
and riots.
I've watched bricks being thrown at officers
during black life.
Now, this
Speaker 1: was addressed extensively.
And there was not only a very long list of
weapons described by the officers, but also
officers described the belief that there were
firearms there, although we should be glad
that the protesters didn't start shooting.
That's something to be happy about, not indignant
about
Speaker 2: this matter and peaceful riots.
I didn't see any of that during this.
So this is going to be a partizan event.
Brace yourselves.
I refuse to leave my show with it tonight.
We will most certainly talk about it.
But there's no way I am giving this sham of
a hearing the due of being at the top of my
program.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: So Sinkfield will be talking about
it, but he is not going to lead the show with
it.
Very principled and defiant production decision,
thereby by Grant Sinkfield, not very deferential
to police.
Not back the blue, not the thin blue line.
It's none of that stuff all of a sudden because
they only care about that when it's convenient.
Here's Republican Congressman Jim Banks.
This is one of the guys that Nancy Pelosi
said, no, you're not going to be on this panel.
He is blaming the police for what happened
on January 6th.
Wow.
Speaker 2: Today was the first day, again,
tragic stories from Capitol Police officers,
experiences that never should have happened.
Right.
If the leadership of the Capitol Police and
those who oversaw the Capitol Police would
have done their job leading up to January
six, we would have trained the Capitol Police
officers.
Speaker 1: So what happened to the police
on January 6th is the fault of the police
because of what they didn't do leading up
to January 6th.
I see.
It's the fact that Trump incited a riot and
then they rioted and they beat police officers
with flagpoles and bear spray and all this
different stuff.
It's the fault of the police guys.
Remember, this guy supports the police.
He's he's all very much pro law enforcement.
Speaker 2: But given them better equipment,
we would have we would have warned them about
the intelligence report.
And I believe that January six would have
been a lot different if the Capitol Police
leadership would have done their job, if there
would have been true leadership at the top
and oversight that didn't happen.
And why are those questions not allowed to
be asked on this committee?
What is the speaker trying to hide by not
allowing me and Jim Jordan in the room to
ask questions about.
Well, Jim
Speaker 1: Jordan, we're going to talk about
a little bit later, but it's becoming increasingly
clear that Jim Jordan has no place on that
committee because he's an accomplice.
He can't possibly investigate it because he
appears to have been an accomplice.
And we'll get to that a little bit later.
Jim Banks, of course, also voted not to certify
the election, part of perpetuating the big
lie, these.
People are truly disgusting.
And then lastly, here is Laura Ingram from
FOX News.
She actually had the gall to call the testimony
from the officers performances and ridiculed
them by giving out performance awards.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: I want you to get to the bottom
of that.
We have more on him in a moment, but it's
not about politics at all and for best performance
in an action role, the winner is Michael Phonon.
Too many are now telling me that hell doesn't
exist or that hill actually wasn't that bad.
The indifference shown to my colleagues is
disgraceful.
Speaker 1: All right, so Laura Ingram making
a mockery of the entire thing, and this is
the movement that claims they support police.
This is the movement that claims that they
are the defenders of law enforcement, but
that's only when it's convenient to them.
These people are really disgusting.